world war one shaped our world in many
many many ways and it's important to
realize it wasn't that long ago it was
not even
100 years ago but it was really the end
of the more traditional
empires it was the end of kingdoms it
really reshaped much of the globes
muster
much more around states defined by
nations rather than states defined by
monarchies or states defined by
empires and it was also the first
war where technology or i would say
modern technology technology has always
been a played a major role in wars in
fact
wars have been a catalyst for technology
often but it was the first time that
much of what we considered to be modern
technology played a huge role
in in the actual carrying out of the war
and to a large degree this is what made
the war
so much bloodier and one could argue
even more protracted
so here i have a bunch of pictures of
the various technologies used in world
war one
here in this picture you have you have a
machine gun
you have a machine gun which allow
obviously allows you to kind of
indiscriminately mow down folks these
guys are
looks like they might be in some type of
a trench and so you can imagine that
combination if viewed from above so
let's say that this is a trench
this is a trench right over here we're
looking from above so there's some
people sitting in the trench
a couple of these folks have machine
guns the rest of the guys just have
rifles over here if you wanted to storm
this trench you'd be in a bad situation
the guy with the machine gun essentially
could just mow people down
could just mow people down they also
tended to use barbed
wire barbed wire wasn't invented in
world war one it was invented many
decades before in the 1800s
but that would make it very hard for
someone to cross this period or
they would get stuck in it and at which
point these guys in the trench could
shoot them down it would be very hard
to shoot the guys in the trench so it
also other than making it very deadly it
gave all the advantages to the defense
so anytime someone wanted to gain ground
especially in one of the fronts where
trench warfare was being used
it was a hugely hugely hugely bloody
affair
the other technology that became into
mainstream use
in world war one was the use of gas and
in particular poison gas
poison poison gas
poison gas and as you see these
gentlemen right over here they're
wearing gas masks
because they're afraid that their
opponent is going to use poison gas and
the benefit of
of gas in particular is let's say you
have an artillery shell that you throw
over and it doesn't hit anybody
but then it starts releasing it starts
releasing a canister
let me do that in a different in a
different color it starts releasing
a canister of gas so the gas i've drawn
in this
purplish color and so it'll affect it
doesn't have to be a direct hit it can
just linger there and
infect that trench and affect everyone
there
and gas warfare was actually the germans
weren't the first to use just just
gas warfare but they were the first to
use very
lethal what we would call poison gas in
particular in 1915
they use chlorine gas so let me write
that down
chlorine chlorine gas which immediately
attacks the respiratory system of the
person who inhales it
and they essentially choke to death
within seconds or minutes
they also used phosgene gas because this
actually did not in
this did not allow the kind of did not
stimulate that choking
that choking reflex in some ways it
could kind of infiltrate the respiratory
system even more it had a delayed effect
so it would kind of linger around and
you have the use of mustard gas mustard
gas was very hard
to protect again against it wouldn't
kind of immediately
have you choked to death like chlorine
gas it would be severe blistering it
would essentially take you
take you out of the battle it was very
hard to protect against and would also
linger around in the trench so it made
the trench a very kind of
like tox toxic environment to work in so
these are very very very ugly weapons i
mean it's
war itself is ugly weapons themselves
are ugly i mean the machine gun is not a
it's not a pleasant weapon it's it can
it can mow people down
but but even folks who view something
like a machine gun is an acceptable
thing
tend to view these things as
particularly particularly
ugly things ugly things to use other
weapons that showed up in world war one
we
talked about this in other videos but
the tank started to become
a factor this right over here is an
american tank obviously you know with
these kind of
these these treads it can it can go in
tough terrain
it's heavily heavily armored uh it could
it could kind of you know when you talk
about this trench type of thing well if
you got a big
hulking beast maybe that could roll
through the barbed wire and
and take some beating and maybe
eventually so you could imagine a
a tank over here it could eventually and
actually the tanks at this time did not
have these kind of these big turrets so
they might have looked something more
like that
but this might be able to actually be
part of an offensive against a trench
like this
we've talked extensively about submarine
warfare in world war one the germans
especially
used it essentially to get to have a
chance against the the dominant
british against the domination the
dominant british navy
uh you unrestricted u-boat warfare was
one of the primary reasons given by the
americans as to why they entered the war
on the inside
on the side of the antand these are kind
of world war one era
us submarines just to give an idea of
how they actually looked
and probably the in some ways the the
the best foreshadowing of
what would play a major major major role
in world in future wars
it was the was the bringing of heavier
than aircraft
into the war so in particular we're
talking about airplanes
so before this you had stuff like
balloons and zeppelins
used for reconnaissance used to see
where we should aim the artillery things
like that
but now you had the right blood brothers
only frankly several years before
inventing the you know the the engine
powered heavier than aircraft
and at first the airplane in the
beginning stages of war was used for
reconnaissance but as the technology
improved as the engines improved
it started to be used for for bombing
started to actually be used for
air-to-air combat
and out of all the folks involved in
air-to-air combat
this gentleman this gentleman right over
here
is probably the most famous although you
might not recognize his name his he's
been kind of charac
turned into a bit of a caricature in in
in the modern world but this is
manfred von richthoven and he was
a a pilot for the germans
and he's more famously known as the red
baron
the red baron and he was called the red
baron because he was actually a baron it
is a title of nobility in imperial
germany
and he painted his plain red so this is
a picture of his plane right over here
so
if i were to color it in i guess this
isn't quite red i should actually
probably
try to get a more reddish color so maybe
this is more of a red
so the color this is obviously a black
and white photograph but maybe if i
color it in for you
you'll get more of the feeling of what
his plane might have looked like it was
a tri plane it had these three wings
right over here
so three levels of wings so whatever his
plane was red
that's why he was called the red baron
and he was famous for
being the most the most lethal pilot
in all of the war he's he has 80
confirmed
kills he was able to down 80 enemy
aircraft so 80
80 confirmed wins i guess you can say in
in in in combat which is more than any
other folks
in world war one so very very famous
pilot
he himself when you're talking about any
of the combatants in world war one did
not have a long life expectancy
the pilots especially this was a
dangerous game and he and he also
despite being the top pilot the top ace
in
in amongst all the pilots in world war
one he also
ended up getting shot in the air in 1918
he literally got shot through the lungs
and the hearts he somehow managed to
land his plane
and when the people ran up to him the
accounts say that his famous last words
as he died
right when they ran up to him was kaput
interesting
and on top of that he's now been kind of
turned to a bit of a caricature i mean
us in the west in the u.s we recognize
the brand red baron red baron pizza
it is named for the red baron for
manfred von
richtoven kind of a strange name i think
for for a pizza company i mean he's not
even italian
but but that's i guess what we know him
for but you see this guy right over here
looks a lot more like tom selleck
than he does then look like the real
manfred von richtoven